y las condensaciones alcohólicas son muy
importantes en química orgánica primero
echemos un vistazo a la adicción
alcohólica si usamos algo como
acetaldehído y un poco de hidróxido de
sodio formaremos este producto el
término haldol es porque tenemos un
aldehído y también un alcohol entonces
empecemos con nuestro acetaldehído
este carbono junto al carbono en el
carbón y lo es el carbono alfa y en este
carbono alfa tenemos 3 protones solo
dibujaré 1 como tenemos hidróxido de
sodio el año en hidróxido entra y
funcionará como una base tomará este
protón dejando estos electrones en
nuestro carbono alfa dibujemos el carbón
ión que resulte
aquí tenemos nuestro carbón hilo y un
hidrógeno del lado derecho del lado
izquierdo tenemos un par de electrones
libres
este es nuestro carbón así que estos
electrones en rosa se movieron hacia el
carbono y podemos dibujar una estructura
de resonancia estos electrones se
moverán hacia acá empujando estos
electrones hacia el oxígeno
entonces nos queda un doble enlace el
oxígeno que ahora tiene tres pares de
electrones libres lo que le da una carga
formal negativa los electrones en rosa
formaron el doble enlace y observen que
la carga negativa es estabilizada con
ayuda del oxígeno esta es la mejor forma
de mostrar nuestro avión enola pto sin
embargo para condensaciones alcohólicas
usaré la estructura del carbón es más
fácil así entonces empecemos con nuestro
carbón
lorre dibujaré por aquí
y una vez que formamos el avión enola
pto podrá funcionar como núcleo filo y
podrá atacar a otra molécula de
acetaldehído no dibujaré el hidrógeno
esto nos servirá para cuando hagamos la
reacción al dórica muy bien sabemos que
el oxígeno es parcialmente negativo y
este carbono en el carbón y lo es
parcialmente positivo entonces es
electro físico quiere electrones y podrá
obtener los de la unión en olate estos
electrones atacan al carbono empujando a
estos electrones hacia el oxígeno
dibujemos el resultado del lado
izquierdo tenemos nuestro oxígeno con
tres pares de electrones libres
y justo aquí formamos un enlace carbono
carbono y del lado derecho tenemos a
nuestro aldehído
así que estos electrones en el cardan
jon atacaron al carbono en el carbón y
lo formaron este enlace carbono carbono
este es nuestro intermediario que es un
al cocido y lo podemos proponer usando
agua así que una molécula de agua entra
y un par de electrones tomará este
protón dibujemos el producto
entonces la adicción alcohólica consiste
en la formación de un enlace carbono
carbono y como continuación tenemos la
condensación alcohólica que es una
reacción muy importante en química
orgánica muy bien echemos un vistazo a
la condensación alcohólica en donde
podremos formar diferentes productos
dependiendo de las condiciones de
reacción por ejemplo si empezamos
nuevamente con acetaldehído hidróxido de
sodio agua y calentamos estamos
cambiando las condiciones de reacción
obtendremos un producto diferente ahora
obtendremos un penal
por el doble enlace y al porque tenemos
un aldehído puede que también escuchen
que se refieren a esto como un alfa beta
in saturado porque este es el carbono
alfa y este es el carbono beta y
formamos un doble enlace aquí entonces
esta es una condensación alcohólica y
para formar este producto empezaremos
con el haldol que formamos en la
reacción anterior
si observamos nuestro haldol este es el
carbono alfa y tenemos dos protones alfa
solo dibujaré uno ahora podemos pensar
en el hidróxido de sodio que funcionará
como una base
h - y tomará este protón dejando estos
electrones en el carbono dibujemos el
resultado
tenemos este carbono con un par de
electrones libres entonces estos
electrones en rosa son los que se
quedaron en el carbono
este es nuestro intermediario ahora para
formar nuestro en 'la como producto
podemos pensar en estos electrones
moviéndose hacia acá para formar un
doble enlace empujando a estos
electrones que se irán con el oxígeno
para formar hidróxido como grupo
saliente entonces podemos decir que el
hidróxido se va y los electrones en rosa
forman este enlace recuerden que para
esto usé la estructura del carbón en
lugar de la del opcional porque de esta
manera es más fácil
en términos de formación del producto el
producto trans será el producto en mayor
cantidad y este es el producto trans
porque los hidrógenos se encuentran de
lados contrarios al doble enlace este es
el producto mayor pero también se
formará una pequeña cantidad del
producto cis
el producto cis será el producto en
menor cantidad porque tiene mayor
impedimento estético que el producto
trans muy bien hagamos uno más sobre
condensación alcohólica
aquí les tengo una reacción y la
pregunta sería cuál es el mecanismo para
la formación de esta enorme bueno
empezaremos con un acetona así que en el
producto tenemos un doble enlace y luego
un acetona obtendremos una en on y para
esto usaremos hidróxido de sodio y
calentaremos pensemos en lo que ocurre
aquí tenemos nuestra acetona y tenemos
dos carbonos alfa son simétricos así que
no importa que protón tomemos digamos
que tomaremos un protón de este lado
entonces dibujemos nuestro carbunión
y ahí está y ahora necesitamos otra
molécula de ciclohexano
y tenemos una situación polarizada en el
carbón y lo parcial negativo y parcial
positivo entonces nuestro año en o latón
núcleo físico atacará justo aquí
empujando a estos electrones hacia el
oxígeno dibujemos el resultado
ahora hemos formado este enlace y este
oxígeno tiene tres pares de electrones
libres lo que le da una carga formal
negativa dibujemos el resto del anillo
sigamos a los electrones estos
electrones en azul se movieron para
formar este enlace carbono carbono que
es muy importante y luego estos
electrones se movieron al oxígeno para
formar nuestro arco óxido ahora podemos
pensar en una molécula de agua para
proteger nuestro intermediario un par de
electrones libres toma este protón
dejando estos electrones dibujemos lo
que nos queda
aquí tenemos nuestro o h y el anillo
muy bien ahora este es el carbono alfa
así que podemos dibujar un protón alfa
nuevamente podemos usar hidróxido como
nuestra base
entonces la base tomará este protón
dejando estos electrones en el carbono
así que nos queda
nuestro anillo
el grupo carbon hilo
un par de electrones libres en este
carbono lo que le da una carga formal
negativa y de este lado tenemos nuestro
h
y el anillo
muy bien así que en el siguiente paso
estos electrones se moverán hacia acá
empujando a estos electrones hacia el
oxígeno dibujemos el producto aquí
tenemos nuestro anillo
un grupo carbón hilo
y por acá hemos formado un doble enlace
sigamos a los electrones estos
electrones en azul se movieron para
formar el doble enlace y estos
electrones en rojo se fueron con el
oxígeno para formar hidróxido como grupo
saliente hemos formado una enana
conjugada como nuestro producto y esta
es una forma de representar el mecanismo
recuerden que las condiciones de
reacción son las que determinan qué tipo
de producto obtenemos en este caso
tenemos una en una con jugada como
producto favorecido entonces traten de
practicar muchas de éstas condensación y
saldo licas